there is an insect called the spotted
lantern fly it's invaded and invaded is
the word 11 states in the northeast and
midwest here's what they look like they
look like they might be malls but the
spotted lanternfly can be identified
with by the bright red wings and also
the spots a lot of people think they're
beautiful gail however
these bugs are actually an invasive
species that threaten trees they
threaten crops they threaten fruit trees
and the usda is asking americans to
smash them smash these insects if you
see them sammy ramsey is an entomologist
at the university of colorado boulder
he's also known as dr buggs and he
shares my shock at this recommendation
to kill insects what's going on here
guys but this is not something that we
frequently tell people that you need to
smash an insect but they are spreading
rapidly across the u.s and we've got to
do something about their populations so
they're not supposed to be here they
originate from asia exactly what makes
them so threatening to to our economy
the way that these organisms work they
have this mouth part it's like a straw
so they can only feed on fluids so they
fly around from tree to tree different
plants apples peaches
even
grapevines and they suck the fluid out
of the fruit which makes the plant less
productive and gives us less of a crop
yield and they're a threat to trees as
well yeah quite a few that's a problem
but it does seem sammy to be murder is
there no other way to do it even as a
little kid you're told you know scoop it
up and put it and put it away because
you often hear that bugs have
there are some redeeming qualities there
are more redeeming qualities and they
have families personally they do have
families
we're making a picture book out of it
now dozens of babies
they're saying but is there no other way
because you also say you you you do need
to smash it is unfortunate but we as the
research community we want you to choose
violence everybody
okay i'm sorry i mean these insects are
absolutely beautiful when you look at
them i mean they give you high fashion
they're the billy porter of insects but
unfortunately it's no one is concerned
about their appearance it's their
appetite that's the issue is it because
there's so many of them that you just
need to smash them they do not have
natural enemies so as you said earlier
normally we we talk about insects as
very important to to the ecosystem but
when a creature doesn't have the the
other organisms that balance it out it
grows out of control and can threaten
the rest of the ego if you just don't
like the feel of a bug under your foot
you don't want to smash or crush or
squash can you spray an insecticide i
would very much advise against that
there are no insecticides that we
currently have here that are labeled for
usage against these insects and when you
use these broad spectrum ones that are
not targeted to them you kill a lot of
insects that are not the intention um
for you to go after so they don't hurt
humans though they don't hurt you they
don't indirectly though in brooklyn
where everyone's afraid they're going to
kill the trees and so they're putting
like a white tape around the trees to
keep them from crawling up and there's
also like squads gangs of people who
have volunteered to go out and find them
and squash these it's bringing families
together think about the family
togetherness now people are getting
together with tennis rackets and just
going after these things but let me ask
you this you say people should try and
catch them before they kill them so it's
one thing you see one you smash it which
i don't want to do anyway but now you're
asking me to bond with it first
and then bring it home and then what and
then
kill my buddy
so i'm not asking you to bond with it in
certain areas of the country that they
haven't reached yet it's actually really
important for you to be able to be the
eyes and ears for your department of
agriculture so in new york just squish
them we don't need any more of them uh
you don't need to catch them and send
them to your your local scientists they
know they're here before you go we were
so fascinated when we saw the piece on
you back in the day you and ben tracy
were doing i think about the data yeah
absolutely but i'm so fascinated by you
because i i think what you do
number one i could never do it bugs
freaked me out what is it about bugs
that is fascinating to you so first of
all you got to try it first no i don't
you no no don't knock it before you try
it
i'm knocking it but what is it about it
for you that you're so fascinated
insects are by far the most fascinating
organisms on this planet and the coolest
thing you've ever stepped on they are
they make up the vast majority of
animals on this planet um hundreds of
times more biomass from insects than
people they beyonce sang a song that
said who runs the world she said girls
girls i'm gonna have to add an addendum
to that girls and bugs bugs truly run
this world we would be nowhere without
without i'm curious to see what you see
when you look at them because i'm
totally creeped out
it's so good to meet you in person
wonderful to meet you as well very
excited i'm glad to be here sammy ramsey
aka dr bugs i just like saying that
books